the U.S Supreme Court has until midnight
tonight to step in and keep a commonly
used abortion pillow on the market
federal judge in Texas ruled that the
drug mifipristone should be suspended
Nationwide even though it has been
available for decades Jan Crawford is at
the Supreme Court with more on what's at
stake here Jan good morning to you well
good morning Gail you know this case is
an effort by conservative Legal Group in
Texas to restrict access to abortion
Nationwide even in states that would
otherwise allow it they're trying to
outlaw that abortion pill saying that
the FDA didn't properly approve it more
than 20 years ago now a federal judge
who's a trump appointee agreed he
revoked that authorization that the FDA
had handed down so the pill could no
longer be used for abortions across the
country a federal appeals court said
that judge went too far but it kept some
limits in place so now we have the Biden
Administration a drug manufacturer here
at the Supreme Court asking the justices
to block those rulings
Jan what do you expect the court to do
now
well I mean Gail I think that the the
justices are going to block those
rulings they're going to uh uh keep this
pill available Nationwide and that's
because at the heart of this case it is
directly at odds with bedrock
conservative principles especially on
the issue of standing and whether these
Challengers even have a right to be in
court in the first place it's not clear
I mean you've got to show you've
suffered some injury or you have a stake
in the case to be able to Sue and if the
court lowers this bot the bar here and
just throws open the courthouse doors to
anyone who's upset about any social
issue you're going to see groups coming
in and trying to get judges to weigh in
on all kinds of things and that is
exactly the opposite of what these
justices have said in previous cases
that the role of the courts should be
Gail
well people on both sides watching this
thank you very much Jan